merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères depuis la mort de Massey
Amini aux mains de la police des mœurs
parce qu'elles ne portait pas
correctement son voile le vendredi volte
qu'il souffle sur l'Iran ne faiblit pas
et malgré la férocité de la répression
le cri femme vie liberté résonne
toujours plus fort dans les rides du
pays à ces trois mots qui incarnent tout
ce que la charia tombe d'étouffer depuis
40 ans le régime des molards réagit de
la seule façon qu'il connaisse par la
brutalité la terreur la reprise des
pendaisons publics vient rappeler au
monde la barbarie à laquelle le pouvoir
iranien est prêt pour se maintenir en
place les témoignages poignants
recueillis au Sénat lors d'une
conférence organisant soutien au club
iranien ont montré à quel point la
violence faisait partie de la nature
profonde de ce régime malgré tout ils
sont toujours aussi nombreux femmes et
hommes à de braver la peur à lever pour
briser les carcans imposés par la
Révolution islamique à se battre pour
des valeurs qui sont aussi les nôtres et
dont nous nous prétendons régulièrement
les défenseurs la France comme l'Europe
reste dans une forme de retraite de
moins en moins compréhensible au
condamnations de principe et au message
de solidarité envers le peuple iranien
n'ont ainsi ce queidé que des sanctions
d'une surprenante faiblesse madame la
ministre concrètement quelles
initiatives le Gouvernement entend-il
prendre pour apporter un soutien en
soulèvement populaire iranien et pour
accentuer la pression internationale sur
les dignitaires du régime iranien